you were working here in PV
[Music]
[Applause]
hi welcome to the third episode of the
new thinking series this series is based
on my upcoming book new thinking which
covers the fascinating grand story of
science and technology and uncovers the
stories of those who built our world but
more on this later
this episode covers something that all
of us have had experience with but have
largely forgotten the mp3 player this
year marks the 20th anniversary of the
mp3 player and today carrying vast
libraries of digital music in our
pockets is now a common occurrence but
what was the mp3 player that started at
all if we try and think back to where it
all began a lot of people would mention
the original iPod but the story of the
mp3 player has its roots all the way
back to the late 1970s in this video
we'll take an interesting look at the
twists and turns throughout that story
but first a quick word from our sponsor
I spent some time trading landing an
information page for the new thinking
book using Squarespace it's interactive
so you can have a look around and see
some of the key characters in the story
these are the builders of our modern
world including the likes of Bill Gates
and Steve Jobs but also some early
pioneers like Douglas Engelbart who
created the graphical user interface and
mouse and others like Alexander Graham
Bell and Nikola Tesla a lot of people
have been asking when the books gonna be
released and as mentioned in a previous
video the release date is January 2019
so Squarespace made this site a breeze
to set up its basically drag drop and
type there's no need to patch anything
or code if you want to make a website
quickly and easily
I do recommend using the service start
your free trial today at ww-where space
com slash ColdFusion to get 10% off your
first purchase okay so let's start the
twisting story of the mp3 player
in 1979 a British scientist came Kramer
and his friend James Campbell came up
with the idea for a cigarette packet
desirest portable solid-state music
player Kramer at the time was 23 in
Campbell only 21 the system called ixi
had a display screen and buttons for
four-way navigation is the sounding
familiar solid-state storage at the time
was severely limited but Kramer fully
expected this to improve he foresaw a
market for reliable high-quality digital
music players that will be popular with
both consumers and record label
companies Kramer soon filed a patent to
start his own company things were going
well initially and there was a
projection of over 328 million dollars
worth of orders he even had Sir Paul
McCartney as a financial backer the
really surprising thing about Kramer's
invention wasn't the player itself of
the distributed network behind it it was
eerily similar to the iTunes Store and
most modern online music stores musical
content could be stored on a central
server and distributed via a telephone
line remember back then there was no
internet and almost no home computers
customers would take their players into
the store and buy music which would be
loaded onto removable chips inside the
player kind of like a tiny cassette this
vision encompassed the end of physical
media in 1979 just to give you an idea
how forward-thinking this was vinyl
records are at their prime and the CD
hadn't even been invented yet here are
some excerpts from Kramer's investor
pitch that he wrote on a typewriter live
performances can be taped and then made
immediately available no physical
inventory and therefore no production
costs entire back catalogue can be put
on sale at almost no cost new risky
artists can be promoted with low-cost
instant micro billing handled centrally
coin-operated vending machines for self
purchasing located in bars filling
stations and supermarkets despite this
amazing vision in 1988 the pattern was
at risk of lapsing and Kramer's company
needed three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in order to renew it
there was a boardroom dispute on the
issue and the
and lapsed meaning that Kramer wouldn't
get any recognition for any products
using this idea this early digital audio
player was never put into production and
even so at the time it was still four
years until the mp3 format came into
existence
mp3 would be the vital key in portable
music so what is mp3 mp3 stands for
mpeg-1 audio layer three
it's basically an audio compression
standard that was designed by a
collaborative group of companies and
engineers in 1992 its aim was to create
audio files which sounded basically the
same as CD quality to a human but only
took up about ten percent of the space
this was done in a pretty smart way you
see if the human ear is limited into
perception there's only so many
frequencies that we can hear an mp3
compression algorithm removes the excess
audio data which is almost unperceivable
to the human ear resulting in a much
smaller file size but with similar sound
quality although the technology for an
mp3 player existed in the early 1990s
American companies were too worried
about being sued by the music industry
to create a portable player of their own
Sony had just bought Columbia Records so
they weren't going to pioneer this new
market the only company brave enough to
take on the concept of an mp3 player and
put it into production was saehan
Information Systems a small Korean
spinoff from Samsung the first portable
mp3 player was the MP man a play on
Walkman I guess launched in March of
1998 by saehan information systems the
flash based mp3 player had either 32 or
64 megabytes of memory that's about 6 to
12 songs it also included an LCD screen
to tell the user what song was currently
playing the cost was around $600 in
today's money
at this time mp3s were just starting to
get distributed across the internet with
mp3.com being established a year earlier
and Napster being launched a year late
on despite it being a pioneering device
the NP man hardly caused a ripple when
it was unveiled for the first time at
Korean booths at an annual tech
conference in Hannover Germany no one
was quite sure what this was mr. junior
bum the vice president of a local tech
company who was there to witness the
event comment quote no matter how the
Korean staff tried to explain what an
mp3 player was people just didn't
understand why they needed such a device
because they could listen to music on
CDs or cassettes a few people accepted
that the mp3 player was something cool
but most people just didn't take it
seriously
end quote a few months later the diamond
rio PMP 300 would go on sale becoming
the second mp3 player in existence but
they were quickly sued by the Recording
Industry Association of America
fortunately they won the case and this
was very important if diamond didn't win
this case we may not have portable mp3
music of any kind today from this time
the mp3 market chugged along but it
still wasn't a revolution as we all know
the iPod came along in 2001 it managed
to solve the biggest problem with mp3
players up until that day the user
interface before the iPod you had to
manually click through songs each one by
one on physical buttons if he had a
thousand songs forget about it the iPod
threw out that idea and decided to go
with a click wheel with built-in
acceleration scrolling navigating
through songs went from being a chore to
being enjoyable this combined with great
industrial design and ample capacity for
over a thousand songs made the iPod a
killer device the iPod became a smash
head a cultural icon and even a poster
child for the new digital age it thrusts
Apple back into the spotlight for the
first time in over a decade but today
even the iPod has fallen by the wayside
the mp3 player in general has become yet
another device consumed by the
versatility of the old doing computer
that you have in your pocket that we
call a smartphone
so what happened to Kane Kramer in 2008
Apple surprisingly acknowledged that
Cain Kramer was the inventor of the iPod
at the time Kramer was a struggling
furniture salesman he explained the
events in an interview to the Daily Mail
quote I was up on a ladder painting when
I got a call from a lady with an
American accent from Apple saying that
she was the head of legal affairs and
they wanted to acknowledge the work that
I had done I must admit that at first I
thought it was a wind-up by my friends
but we spoke for some time with me still
of the letter end quote
so what happened there are revelations
that came to light after a patent
holding company called burst sued Apple
claiming iPod infringed on his patent
Apple flew Kramer to the US to give
evidence in their defense and used his
original 1979 drawings of the ixi device
as evidence that Kramer was in fact the
inventor of the iPod I think Apple
essentially just used Kramer to get out
of hot water but he did get something
out of the whole ordeal white Apple did
give me an iPod but it broke down after
eight months and quite Kramer was paid
for the time spent in the legal defense
but did not receive any royalties from
the iPod sales so that is the story of
the mp3 player I just want to talk to
you guys for a second as some of you
know I've been striving to make more
videos along the lines of what you guys
want to see it's been a bit tricky I
recently did a poll in YouTube and found
out that there are a few of you that
like the old of style videos of
Technology history so that was one of
the reasons for this video today and I
just want to gauge your reaction if you
did enjoy it let me know and if you
hated it let me know as well and just
try and understand what's best here
thanks for watching that this has been -
go go if you've just stumbled across
this channel feel free to subscribe and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good life
[Music]